he was 10 minutes you said yeah no I was
told you wouldn't be back for a proper
goodbye
I already told Craig that I gave the
rumor about him so he's expecting that I
forgot already
I did yes I remember think about it it's
not a negative I've said that he told me
what it was oh yeah I'll go with that
yeah I've heard that before I've heard
it before how do you ever take penis
Craig I don't know enough so I guess it
must have grown with the legend yeah
well the guys have heard of the bat I've
heard about you I've heard of a chaplain
I've heard about James Woods and I've
heard John Boyd
yes our chaplain at huge dick Kevin Hart
Charles Darwin let me ask you no [ __ ]
Frank Chaplin I heard about Don Knotts
and let me ask you a question right
right so I meet the guy and I'm sitting
next to him on a couch would you look
of course 100 you wouldn't yeah we're
trying I'm trying to sit over the table
right now the whole time I'm talking to
him I kept going are those pleats and
he's being all serious I was born in
West Virginia oh my god I just wanted to
say I'm not done I never heard that
about Don Knotts but it makes sense it
makes sense he was a nice skinny guy be
honest Apple yeah apples the key I don't
know it just seemed like those scrawny
country guys have a giant dick but
you've heard this Colin throughout the
industry many many hundred years ago I
always forgot it but Jim just happened
to say I heard the same rumor so you
losing a lot though a lot of wind a lot
of think so I mean I used to be able to
blow myself I can just talk about that
yeah really yeah you can say it and I'll
never forget I was an acting class and
George Wallace you know the King heard
this he was so fascinated until there to
show him how it works yeah yep they have
to be both they got a rib when a guy
talking about blowing himself he's not
bragging about his limberness
you have to be both that's not a
dexterity brag everybody said that pro
wrestler leaping Lanny Poffo used to be
able to do the same thing and he would
charge guys five dollars to watch him in
the locker room that's right that's
right do you ever I mean I would have
been over Wow no comment anyway
well you wouldn't want to see leaping
Lanny Poffo performance you think you
could really do that I in the day yeah I
put the pencil down there yeah and
George goes cold get that thing and I
went down and got it how does one find
out that they have that ability I've
always worked as everyone tries you tell
me one guy yeah I tried and I kept
trying when I was a kid you know and one
day was shangri-la I succeeded as well
it was just on other people practice
makes perfect
sure does so yeah I had heard happy you
you remember the guys you hear that
rumor about so I just ends was there a
day in your adult life when you realized
that the magic was gone that you'd lost
the ability yeah I just didn't really
have the desire anymore for the resume
do you feel like you feel like you still
could if you tried or do you also think
that the body and the mind you talk
about symbiotic relationship if I could
like it's a theory you don't think that
I have tried and has because you could
think I completely retired you know
golfing in Montana once in a while I
used to want to go out and you want it
you want to run the race once in a while
wander down in that area
you know and just you don't have it
especially my wife is starting to go to
menopause so me could you finish
yourself it was one of those things like
ron jeremy would do it this is just kind
of like bob on the thing but could you
actually finish
for a second let him answer you don't
look at him that is true I don't really
know Jim that is the lazy eye can you
think myself directed it right to call
askew Craig right in the eyes your own
mouth yep
that's the question on everybody's mind
where'd you work the road for as many
years as I have this is a conversation
when you're training yourself on how to
do radio media training and this is a
media this is right out of the gate
right yeah you know your prep you do a
little show prep maybe I'll lead them
into some bit right but now we're open a
bit you did offer that up though with
George Wallace that's fascinating he he
opened it up he opened up the penis I
had mentioned it before okay so I did
not bring I did not walk in your go hey
guys this is all about my Showtime
special and my big car okay that's all I
would do I didn't pass a piece of paper
to say let's go here honey the same
won't hurt my name yet with the question
we're here with nobody else can see me
yeah big [ __ ] the question is for the
confirmation he's supposed to be at his
heart examination right he comes in just
to say yeah I heard it too the question
is at the point of climbing bring it
George was a mystery man with a giant
[ __ ] who takes care of himself in his
friend he George Wallace his idol was in
studio Craig shoemaker is his name